schönen guten tag herzlich willkommen zu
unserer online vorlesung in der wir uns
heute mit der narration analyse nach
fritz schütze beschäftigen werden diese
vorlesung ist teil einer trilogie von
online vorlesungen zur qualitativen
sozialforschung
sie finden also in unserer mediathek
eine erste vorlesung in der wir uns
zunächst mit der datenerhebung
beschäftigen mit einer spezifischen
methode der erhebung qualitative daten
nämlich mit dem narrativen interview
diese vorlesung ist nun der zweite teil
der trilogie wir lernen nämlich jetzt
eine methode kennen mit der wir diese
empirischen daten auswerten können im
generation analyse und es wird dann noch
eine dritte vorlesung geben der wir eine
alternative aber auch durchaus an
generation analyse anschließende
auswertungsmethode kennen lernen nämlich
die grounded theory methodologie lassen
sie uns zu beginn noch einmal
zusammenfassen was wir an erzählt
theoretischen grundannahmen zum
negativen interview festgehalten hatten
wir hatten gesagt dass man mittels
narrativer verfahren besonders
authentische empirische daten erheben
kann weil nämlich mit dem narrativen
interview alltagskommunikation emittiert
wird weil wir dem probanden den verlauf
seiner stegreif erzählung selber
bestimmen lassen und somit den einfluss
von uns als forschendes minimieren
können
wir hatten gesagt dass erlebnisse im
gedächtnis in vier kognitiven figuren
abgespeichert und aufgeschichtet werden
nämlich die erzählt reger die handelnden
akteure eines prozesses die
ereigniskette des erzählten prozesses
besonders verdichtete situation und die
thematische gesamt gestalt die
evaluieren de die bewertende komponente
des erzählten prozesses und diese vier
kognitiven figuren ja werden reanimiert
wenn ich einen erlebten prozess in form
einer stegreif erzählung noch einmal
erzähle und werden gesagt dass während
einer stegreif erzählung 32
des alls helens wirken nämlich der
detaillierung zwang der dazu führt dass
der erzähler uns die geschichte so
detailliert erzählt dass wir sie
nachvollziehen und verstehen können
zum zweiten der kondensiert zwang der
noch einmal deutlich macht dass wenn ich
einen prozess erzähle ich nur bestimmte
aspekte des prozesses erzählen kann und
deswegen relevanten in dem sinne
festlegen muss dass ich diejenigen teile
des prozesses erzählen die ich als
erzähler für relevant halten und
dergestalt schließungs zwang der unteren
dazu unter anderem dazu führt dass
erzählungen abgeschlossen und von
anderen erzählungen abgegrenzt werden
das sollten wir also noch mal im
hinterkopf haben wenn wir jetzt im
folgenden schauen was die narration
analyse eigentlich tut
zunächst sollte man wissen dass sie von
einem spannungsverhältnis zweier
logischen lebt die wir in einer stegreif
erzählung sehen können
das ist zum einen die logik des handelns
also wie hat der akteur tatsächlich im
rahmen eines sozialen prozesses agiert
gehandelt zum anderen ist es die logik
der darstellung also die frage wie wird
dieser prozess im rahmen einer stegreif
erzählung dargestellt und geschildert
wenn wir mit der logik des handelns
anfangen dann können wir zunächst einen
von drei text typen zu ordnen nämlich
die erzählung selber ja stegreif
erzählung beinhalten also nicht nur
genuine erzählungen sondern gleich auch
noch beschreibungen argumentation
zunächst aber die erzählung erzählungen
wie können wir sie erkennen wenn wir das
transkript eines negativen interviews
vor uns haben
nun sie spielen häufig in der
vergangenheit also sie tun es immer aber
auch sprachlich sind sie meistens in der
vergangenheitsform formuliert in
erzählungen werden die erzähl träger
also die handelnden akteure signifikant
eingeführt im regelfall in dem ihre
grundeigenschaften ihre für den prozess
relevanten grundeigenschaften
thematisiert werden
im rahmen von erzählungen schildert der
erzähler darüber hinaus die situationen
des prozesses die für ihn besondere
relevanz haben besondere orte die zeiten
die umstände in denen etwas passiert
wurde und schließlich schildern die
erzähler vor und nachgeschichte ja mit
denen das eigentliche erzähl segment von
anderen abgegrenzt wird sie merken also
hier spiegeln sich zunächst diese vier
kognitiven figur an einer stegreif
erzählung wieder
ich möchte ihnen das aber auch noch mal
an einem beispiel verdeutlichen also
nehmen wir an wir sitzen nun schön im
café zusammen und ich erzähle ihnen von
meinem letzten wochenende ja dann könnte
eine erzählung er vielleicht ungefähr
wie in der folgenden weiße beginnen
ich sage ihnen ich erzähle ihnen am
samstag da war ich auf der party beim
stefan m
da merken sie erzählungen sind auf die
vergangenheit ausgerichtet auf das
vergangene wochenende an dem ich auf
dieser party war als nächstes führe ich
dann die relevanten personen ein ich
sage also am samstag war ich auf einer
party mit stefan und er hat nicht diese
biene getroffen
das wäre also ein offenbar relevanter
erzählt reger in relevante erzähle
trägerin in unsere stegreif erzählung am
samstag also war ich auf dieser party
beim stefan da habe ich die sabine
getroffen und das ist ja eigentlich eine
ganz schüchtern erzähle ich jeden ich
stelle also eine grundeigenschaft von
sabine in den vordergrund und wichtig
ist in der narration analyse mit zu
denken wie ich das tue ja sie merken zum
beispiel ich habe vielleicht mit einem
kleinen augenzwinkern dieses wort
eigentlich betont und das habe ich als
erzähler sicherlich nicht ohne grund
getan ja eigentlich ist dieser bienen
ganz schüchtern und hier merken sie auch
noch mal dass es wichtig ist wenn sie
ein narratives interview transkribieren
dass sie derartige informationen
beibehalten
wie zb indem sie kenntlich machen dass
dieses eine wort eigentlich betont
worden ist im regelfall tut man das
indem man diese worte unterstreicht nun
würde unsere erzählung weitergehende am
samstag war ich auf der party mit stefan
darf ich die sabine getroffen das ist ja
eigentlich eine ganz nüchterne aber mit
der habe ich bestimmten stunde auf dem
balkon gesessen
das heißt hier ist der punkt an dem ich
die situation schildere ja in der der
prozess stattgefunden hat denen ich im
folgenden erzählen werde und dann
geschichte noch ein bisschen weiter ich
merke nämlich offenbar als erzähler dass
ihnen noch eine information fehlt damit
sie die erzählung nachvollziehen können
damit sie meine geschichte verstehen
können und deshalb schildere ich
sozusagen noch eine vorgeschichte ja ich
sage nämlich da hatten wir aber schon
zwei flaschen wein getrunken als wir auf
dem balkon gesessen haben
insgesamt also und vielleicht merken sie
es ist durchaus ein idealtypischer als
helfer auf der am samstag dabei ich auf
der party nahm stefan da hab ich die
sabine getroffen
das ist ja eigentlich eine ganz
schüchtern aber mit er habe ich bestimmt
eine stunde auf dem balkon gesessen aber
da hatten wir auch schon zwei flaschen
wein getrunken und an der stelle würde
meine erzählung vielleicht doch die
spannenderen teile meiner erzählung
weiter gehen ja aber so fangen
erzählungen an sie spielen in der
vergangenheit
ich führe relevante personen mit ihren
grundeigenschaften ein ich schildere
situationen und wenn sie um zum
verständnis nötig sind
schiebe ich vorgeschichte nein das ist
also die lob des handelns die ich in
einer erzählung finden
die logik der darstellung wie ich etwas
erzähle die beinhaltet nun zwei
verschiedenen texten zum einen nämlich
die beschreibung ja das sind also
statische sachverhalte die ich in einer
statischen weise schildere zum beispiel
eigenschaften ohne auf den zeitlichen
verlauf oder den wandel dieser
eigenschaften einzugehen beispielsweise
hätte ich ihnen jetzt diesen balkon auf
dem ich mit sabine gesessen habe noch
etwas detaillierter schildern wenn das
für meine erzählung relevant wäre oder
ich könnte vielleicht sagen was es auf
der party zu essen gab was zu trinken
gab welche musik da gelaufen ist könnte
unter umständen für meine geschichte
relevant sein und dann würde ich diese
beschreibungen der situation hinzufügen
die zweite textsorte oder der zweite
text typ den wir in der logik der
darstellung finden das sind
argumentationen argumentation bedeutet
dass der erzähler zu etwas stellung
nimmt
zu seinem handeln zum handeln des
anderen dass er analysiert oder auch
bewertet sein handeln oder das andere
das handeln anderer und diese bewertung
die würde man dann evaluation also im
prinzip sind innovationen noch mal ein
spezialfall des textes argumentation
das könnte ich zum beispiel machen wenn
ich am ende meiner erzählung sagen würde
das war eine wirklich interessante
partie es könnte ein guter schluss als
eine gute oder meiner erzählung sein und
da würde sich daneben um eine evaluation
handeln und diese drei text typen die
sind für uns wichtig wenn wir nun
konkret einfach einsteigen und eine
derart generation analyse durchführen
wollen
wichtig ist außerdem zu wissen dass
erzählungen gegliedert sind in bestimmte
erzähl segmente er ich kann also
erzählungen in verschiedene abschnitte
unterteilen
im normalfall sind diese abschnitte
dieser erzähl segmente chronologisch
aneinandergereiht und spiegeln den
erzählten prozess wieder
manchmal gibt es aber auch diese
einschübe von denen ich gerade schon
sprach dass ich ein hintergrund
erzählung einfüge um ihnen etwas
verständlich zu machen
eine zweite variante wären sogenannte
belegt
erzählungen wenn ich also eine
evaluation beispielsweise vornehme und
sage es war eine schöne party und ihnen
dann belegen erzähle warum es eine
schöne party war auch das gucken wir uns
gleich noch an einem genaueren beispiel
an wichtig ist wenn wir nun in
generation analyse hingehen und das
transkript dass wir vor uns liegen haben
in verschiedene erzähle segmente
untergliedern
dann müssen wir wissen dass diese erzähl
segmente häufig sehr unterschiedliche
detaillierungsgrad aufweisen
es gibt lange erzähle segmente und kurze
erzähl segmente es gibt solche die sehr
detailreich geschildert werden und
solche wo eine erzählung sehr an der
oberfläche bleibt und im sinne eines
erzählt stumpfes vielleicht gar nicht zu
ende erzählt wird und wir sollten auch
festhalten dass es sich bei der
segmentierung einer transkribierten
erzählung immer um eine analytische
untergliederung handelt also eine solche
die wir als forschende vornehmen
das bedeutet auch wenn wir gleich eine
ration analyse machen
es gibt dafür sozusagen keinen königsweg
herr verschiedene forschende werden
erzählungen in verschiedener weise
segmentieren das ist aber nicht schlimm
da diese untergliederung uns zunächst
mal als methodisches werkzeug dient ja
wir haben ein größeres ziel wir wollen
eine forschungs frage beantworten und da
ist die untergliederung einer erzählung
jetzt zunächst mal nur ein puristischer
zwischenschritt ja ein tipp möchte ich
ihnen noch geben für die praxis wenn sie
nun selber hingehen
er und ein ein transkript im sinne einer
ration analyse segmentieren
dann sollten sie dabei zunächst nicht zu
fein vorgehen
ja sie sollten es sollte am ende nicht
so aussehen dass jeder satz des
transkripts sein eigenes segment ist
sondern ich würde ihnen empfehlen damit
sie einen besseren überblick behalten
zunächst eher grob zu segmentieren
das ist übrigens ein unterschied zur
grounded theory methodologie die wir in
der 3
online vorlesung zur qualitativen
sozialforschung kennenlernen da werde
ich ihnen empfehlen dass sie tatsächlich
satz für satz
das transkript kodieren aber hier die
segmente sollten nicht zu feingliedrig
sein
ein marker ein kennzeichen das ihm
helfen kann wenn sie erzählungen
segmentieren sind die sogenannten rahmen
schaltelemente häufig sind die segmente
nämlich deutlich erkennbar voneinander
abgegrenzt und zwar sowohl am anfang ja
häufig beginnt ein
als herr segment mit solchen signal
worden wie und dann oder später oder
drei wochen zuvor oder solchen
formulierungen ja und häufig gibt es
auch ein rahmen scheint element am ende
eines jeden erzähl segments das häufig
ein bilanzierenden charakter hat ja dass
ein resümee des gerade dargestellt dass
gerade erzählten darstellt dann würden
wir von einer cola sprechen auch das
gucken wir uns gleich am beispiel an
es ist nur wichtig dass wir für die
generation analyse wissen es gibt
derartige als segmente die wir
identifizieren sollen in analytischer
weise und dabei können uns rahmen
schaltelemente helfen diese gedanken
also die narration analyse wurden
entwickelt von fritz schütze und zwar in
den 1970 er jahren und zwar in einem
interessanten zusammenhang den ich ihnen
kurz sagen möchte sie wurden entwickelt
in einer studie zunächst einmal ja das
ist ja ein kennzeichen vieler methoden
der empirischen sozialforschung also
dass die methoden eben nicht am
reißbrett entwickelt wurden sondern dass
sie im zusammenhang mit einer konkreten
studie mit einer konkreten fragestellung
entwickelt wurden und das ist auch im
fall der narration analyse so fritze
nämlich interessierte sich für kommunale
machtstrukturen es gab in den 1960 70er
jahren ja flächendeckende
gemeindefusionen
es gab neugliederung von kommune und das
war der prozess für den er sich
eigentlich interessierte und nun ist er
ins feld gegangen und hat mit relevanten
akteuren zunächst interviews geführt
also mit lokal und regionalpolitiker und
stellte aber sehr schnell fest dass
große erzähler hemmungen gibt denn man
muss dazu wissen diese kommunale
neugliederung war mit vielen emotionen
auch verknüpft ja menschen haben ihre
posten verloren oder neue posten
gewonnen ja gemeinden wurden andere
gemeinden zugegeben dass sie wurden ein
gemeinde da waren emotionen im spiel die
zu erzählen führten und deshalb hat
fritz schütze einen sehr interessanten
trick wie ich finde angewandte er hat
die politiker nämlich gar nicht nach dem
prozess der neugliederung selber gefragt
sondern er hat sie sehr konkret gebeten
von der namensfindung für die neue
gemeinde zu erzählen und das wiederum
haben seine interviewpartner offenbar
sehr bereitwillig gemacht ja sie haben
erzählt davon wie es zum namen der neu
gegliederten gemeinde cham und mussten
in diesem zusammenhang natürlich
hintergrund erzählungen einfügen die
sich dann mit dem beschäftigt haben was
fritz schütze eigentlich interessiert ja
also das ein sehr interessanter trick
gar nicht genau nach dem zu fragen was
man eigentlich wissen will
weil es mit emotionen beladen ist und
von rtl hemmung gekennzeichnet ist
sondern nach etwas zu fragen wovon die
interviewpartner gerne erzählen und dann
in diesem zusammenhang ja durch die
zwänge des erzählens zu provozieren dass
sie auch das interessieren was man
erzählen was einen als forschende
interessiert die narration analyse die
im rahmen dieser studie entwickelt wurde
besteht aus sechs schritten zunächst
sind es vier schritte die sich auf den
jeweiligen einzelfall beziehen
eine formale textanalyse die
strukturelle inhaltliche beschreibung
die analytische abstraktion die
wissensanalyse und im anschluss folgen
zwei schritte die ich es dann führen
kann wenn ich mehrere fälle erhoben habe
dann nämlich
nicht fünfter einen kontrast even fall
vergleich durchführen
und 6 das wäre der finale schritt
sozusagen unser ziel als forscher am 6
kann ich dann ein theoretisches modell
entwickeln beispielsweise eine typologie
schauen wir uns diese sechs schritte mal
ein bisschen genauer an
beginnen wir also mit der formalen
textanalyse die heben schon ein bisschen
angeklungen ist dass wir bei rahmen
schaltelemente unterzahl segmente
gesprochen haben
schauen wir zunächst das frisst schütze
selber schreibt er sagt formale
indikatoren in erzähl texten sind
insbesondere die narrativen rahmen
schaltelemente die anzeigen dass eine
darstellung einheit abgeschlossen ist
und nunmehr die nächste folgt der erste
analyse schritt die formale textanalyse
besteht mit den darin zunächst einmal
alle nicht mehr aktiven textpassagen zu
eliminieren und sodann den bereinigten
erzählt text auf seine formalen
abschnitte hin zu segmentieren etwas
sperrig formuliert das was wir gerade
schon gesagt hat mir vorm eine
textanalyse ist also ein rein
technischer schritt zunächst mal ich
beschäftige mich nicht mit inhalt
sondern ich beschäftige mich mit in
formaler hinsicht mit dem text segment
ihre ihn in die verschiedenen erzähl
segmente und darüber hinaus grenze ich
nun die drei text typen von einer public
and identifiziere also für jedes erzähl
segment handelt es sich um eine
wirkliche erzählung handelt es sich um
eine beschreibung oder handelt es sich
um eine argumentation
das ist wichtig weil in den folgenden
beiden schritten generation analyse nun
zunächst nur die genuinen erzählung
nicht also die beschreibung und
argumentation berücksichtigt werden
und das lässt sich erzählt theoretisch
begründen wir hatten ja nämlich gesagt
dass mittels narrativer interviews
besonders authentische daten erhoben
werden ja also dadurch dass während
einer stegreif erzählung die vier
kognitiven figuren in denen das erlebnis
in unserem gedächtnis abgespeichert ist
dass diese reanimiert werden
dadurch hat der erzählte prozess ja eine
nähe zum tatsächlich erlebten prozess er
bildet diesen analog ab das hatten wir
in der vorlesung zum aktiven interview
als homo logi annahme bezeichnet und
deshalb legt fritz schütze in den ersten
schritten generation analyse so viel
wert auf diese erzählung weil er sagt
das ist tatsächlich ein abbild des
prozesses den 4
mit der narration analyse analysieren
erforschen wollen
ein hinweis muss sich dazu noch geben
das sehen wir auch gleich anhand eines
beispiels häufig ist es so dass ein
erzähl segment tatsächlich in der
hauptsache ja einer der drei text typen
zuzuordnen ist beispielsweise handelt es
sich also um eine erzählung in erster
linie sehr wohl kann es sein dass in
dieser erzählung aber auch
beispielsweise argumentative passagen
vorkommen zum beispiel weil die
erzählung mit einer bilanzierenden coda
abgeschlossen wird
dadurch sollte man sich nicht verwirren
lassen sondern es geht um die frage also
welchen text typ stellt ein erzähl
segment in erster linie da dann haben
wir den ersten schritt schon beendet und
kommen jetzt ein stückchen weiter gehend
zum zweiten schritt nämlich der
strukturellen inhaltlichen
beschreibungen der segment fortschritt
zu schreibt im zweiten analyse schritt
wird sodann eine strukturelle
inhaltliche beschreibung der darstellung
stücke durchgeführt die strukturelle
inhaltliche beschreibung arbeitet die
einzelnen zeitlich begrenzten
prozessstrukturen des lebenslaufs heraus
das heißt was wir nun tun ist wir
identifizieren sozusagen funktionale
zusammenhänge zwischen den erzähl
segmenten ja welche funktion erfüllt ein
segment für die gesamte stegreif
erzählung handelt es sich beispielsweise
um die haupt erzählung oder handelt es
sich um ein hintergrund erzählung oder
handelt es sich um eine beleg erzählung
und ich beschäftige mich jetzt stärker
mit dem
inhalt der erzählt segment deswegen
heißt es ja strukturelle inhaltliche
beschreibung und das tut fritz schütze
durchaus in einer weise die an
hermeneutische auswertungsmethoden
angelehnt sind nämlich um zu verstehen
wie der erzähler in dem prozess den er
uns erzählt gehandelt hat ist es
hilfreich so etwas zu tun wie
alternative lesarten zu bilden
es ist also immer hilfreich sich zu
fragen wie hätte der akteur eigentlich
in einer situation handeln können und
das zu vergleichen mit dem wir
tatsächlich gehandelt hat wenn ich das
tun möchte diese alternativen lesarten
bilden möchte dann ist eine heuristik
sehr hilfreich die fritz schütze
entwickelt hat er hat nämlich drei typen
oder drei grundtypen des handelns
voneinander abgegrenzt es geht hier
wohlgemerkt um biografie forschung also
ein biographisches handel
und da unterscheidet fritz schütze zum
ersten jahr also biografische
handlungsmuster das wären solche
handlungen bei denen der erzähler
tatsächlich gemäss eigener biografischer
ziele handelt in denen er also das heft
des handelns fest in der hand hat und
die deutlich zu unterscheiden sind von
ihrem genauen gegenteil nämlich dem
zweiten grundtyp des handels den von
fritz sogenannten verlaufs kurven herbei
verlaufs kurven wäre es nämlich so dass
der erzähler die handlungsmacht verliert
das heft des handelns aus der hand gibt
und die situation ihm entgleitet er also
eher von äußeren umständen
zudem handeln getrieben wurde dass er
uns nun erzählt darüber hinaus gibt es
noch den institutionellen rahmen der
wäre immer dann gegeben wenn der
erzähler nicht selbst das heft des
handelns in der hand hat sondern von
institutionalisierten rahmenbedingungen
bestimmt wird ja dass das erinnert sehr
stark an dieses soziologische konnte
der totalen institutionen ja da sind ja
einige beispiele zum beispiel ein
gefängnis ja oder eine psychiatrische
klinik ja in der die patienten bzw
insassen ihren ihre handlungs struktur
nicht selbst definieren können sondern
wohin von außen eine struktur vorgegeben
wird innerhalb derer sie handeln müssen
das muss aber nicht so drastisch sein
wie in den beiden genannten beispiel
gefängnis oder psychiatrie ja auch eine
universität beispielsweise ist eine
institution und sie gibt bestimmte
regeln und strukturen vor innerhalb
derer sie sie als studierende handeln
beispielsweise wird durch curricula der
verlauf ihres studiums bestimmt da wird
es sich also eher um einen
institutionellen rahmen handeln als um
ein biographisches handlungsmuster und
ein vierter grund ist das handels in
fritzlar unterscheidet das sind
biografische wandlungsprozess
die sind für uns spannend wenn wir noch
einmal über die pilger studie sprechen
die ich ihnen in der vorlesung zur
narrativen interview vorgestellt habe da
haben es nämlich ganz explizit mit
menschen zu tun die sich in lehnin allen
phasen in übergangsphasen ihrer
biografie befinden
und wenn man so will so schreibt es
wenigstens fritze damit an sich ganz
neue seiten kennen lernen das ist also
was ich im zweiten schritt der narration
analyse tour
ich identifiziere funktionale
zusammenhänge von erzähl segmenten ja
gewinne dadurch einen eindruck von der
struktur einer erzählung und ich wende
mich dem inhalt zu und identifiziere die
handlungsweisen des erzählers und ordne
sie das ist zumindest hilfreich in
dieser heuristik der vier grundtypen des
biografischen handelns ein
im dritten schritt gehe ich dann noch
ein stück weiter jetzt folgt nämlich
eine abstraktion eine analytische
abstraktion schütze schreibt dazu das
ergebnis der strukturellen inhaltliche
beschreibung wird im dritten abschnitt
der auswertung nämlich in der
analytischen abstraktion von den details
der einzelnen dargestellten
lebensabschnitte gelöst
die abstrahierenden struktur aussagen zu
den einzelnen lebensabschnitten werden
vielmehr systematisch miteinander in
beziehung gesetzt und auf dieser
grundlage wird die biografische
gesamtform herausgearbeitet das heißt
was ich an dieser stelle tue ist ich
entwickle für mich einen abstrakteren
strukturplan des vom erzähler
geschilderten prozesses ich fasse
sozusagen alle seine handlungen zur
einer biografischen gesamt gestalt
zusammen um daraufhin im vierten schritt
der ist analyse
diese von mir gerade entwickelte gesamt
gestalt der handlungsweisen zu
vergleichen mit den argumentationen und
beschreibungen einer erzählung ja also
jetzt kommen diese beiden anderen text
chip wieder ins spiel ich konzentriere
mich jetzt nicht nur auf die genuinen
erzählung sondern schaue jetzt auch wie
passen eigentlich die erzählung zu den
argumentationen und beschreibungen die
mit der erzähler liefert das heißt die
logik des handelns wird der logik der
darstellung gegenüber gestellt was ich
nicht dabei frage ist zum beispiel
beschreibt sich der erzähler selbst
sowie auch tatsächlich gehandelt hat
oder gibt es etwa divergenzen die ich
erkennen kann ja zwischen einerseits der
biografischen selbstbeschreibung und dem
tatsächlich tatsächlichen verlauf der
biografie sowie sich vom erzähler
geschildert wurde
die hermanns hat da ein wie ich finde
sehr illustrative beispiel er schreibt
berichtet ein erzähler etwa bei der
darstellung seine lebensgeschichte immer
wieder von für seinen lebensweg
wichtigen erfahrungen bei denen er stets
in der helferrolle war als ältere bruder
zum beispiel als jugendgruppenleiter und
dass er anschließend bei der
studienfachwahl das fach sozialarbeit
gewählt hat um anderen zu helfen
dann finden wir eine entsprechung
zwischen der erfahrungs auf schichten
und der eigene theorie anderen worten
die logik des handelns ist hier
deckungsgleich mit der logik der tasche
wenn aber schreibt weiter wenn dagegen
jemand seine lebensgeschichte erzählt
und dabei stets von den verschiedensten
konkurrenz kämpfen um status berichtet
und er dann unvermittelt als motiv für
die wahl seines studienfaches medizin
den wunsch anderen zu helfen angibt dann
ist dies zunächst eine argumentative
erklärung die nicht durch die
erzählungen des ereignisses stroms
abgedeckt ist sie muss dabei nicht
zwangsläufig unglaubwürdig seien aber
die diskrepanz zwischen der erzählung
und der argumentation die müsste
erklärbar seien und dass diese
diskrepanzen zu entdecken die sind einer
der sehr spannenden und
erkenntnisreichen punkte einer nation
analyse immer dann wenn ich mich frage
warum eigentlich
da passt die logik des handelns also
dass tatsächlich erlebte nicht mit der
logik darstellung zusammen
das sind die ersten vier schritte
generation so analyse die die ich
jeweils am einzelfall vollziehen kann
die beiden nächsten schritte gehen dann
erst wenn ich mehrere fälle erhoben habe
zunächst nämlich vergleiche ich im
fünften schritt die fälle kontrast tief
miteinander
ich vergleiche also die von mir
identifizierten biografischen
strukturpläne und die biografischen
gesamtform um miteinander und da gibt es
zwei strategien mit denen ich das tun
kann ich kann das nämlich einerseits
tool mit etwas das wir minimalen
vergleichen und andererseits tun mit
etwas das wir maximal im vergleich
hätten im fall des minimalen vergleiches
suchen wir also gezielt nach fällen die
sich möglichst ähnlich sind im fall des
maximalen vergleiches gezielt nach
fällen die möglichst unterschiedlich
sind das damit zum beispiel auch im
rahmen der pilger studie gemacht
deshalb möchte ich ihnen das
anhand eines beispiels schildern wir
haben uns ja in dieser studie gefragt
also warum eigentlich ja pilgern so
viele und immer mehr menschen auf dem
jakobsweg und nehmen wir an wir hätten
jetzt ein erstes interview geführt
mit einer pilgerin die uns vom tod ihres
vaters erzählt dann könnten wir während
wir diesen fall analysieren auf den
gedanken kommen dass diese frau mit
einer lebenskrise konfrontiert war und
dass diese lebenskrise
der grund dafür ist dass sie auf den
jakobsweg gegangen ist und wenn wir
diesen gedanken haben ja dann würden wir
zunächst nach ähnlichen fällen ausschau
halten
also aber nur ähnlich nicht gleich ja
also wir würden nicht nach anderen
menschen suchen die einen nahen
angehörigen verloren haben und auf den
jakobsweg gelandet sind sondern wir
würden suchen nach anderen pilgern die
ebenfalls in einer lebenskrise stecken
und dann würden wir beispielsweise
jemanden finden der von seinem partner
verlassen wurde
oder wir werden jemanden finden der
gerade seinen job verloren hat
ja und so hätten wir im rahmen eines
minimalen vergleiches drei ähnliche
fälle die ganz unterschiedliche
biografische auslöser habe aber eine
große gemeinsamkeit alle drei pilger tod
des vaters trennung vom partner verlust
des jobs haben als gemeinsamkeit eine
lebenskrise und so schaffen wir es durch
den minimalen fall vergleich vom
einzelfall zu abstrahieren hin zu einem
typus dem typus der lebenskrise und wenn
wir diesen typus lebenskrise vom vom
einzelfall abstrahiert haben ihn
festgezurrt haben
durch verschiedene ausprägungen dann
würden wir zur strategie des maximalen
fall vergleichs wechseln also jetzt
würden wir einen pilger suchen
der aus einem völlig anderen grund dem
jakobsweg geht und treffen dann
beispielsweise ein schüler der nach
seinem abitur pilgert und während der
datenauswertung können wir dann den
gedanken haben
vielleicht ist es ja so dass auch
menschen in bestimmten biografischen
übergangsphasen pilgern und dann würden
wir im rahmen eines minimalen
vergleiches jetzt wieder nach ähnlichen
fällen suchen und würden beispielsweise
eine absolventin treffen die nach
beendigung ihres studiums den jakobsweg
geht oder wir würden einen rentner
treffen der nach dem ende seines
berufslebens auf den jakobsweg gegangen
ist und im rahmen des minimalen fall
vergleichs würden wir hier genau
dasselbe tun wir bei der lebenskreis wir
würden diese drei einzelfälle
abstrahieren zu einem typus den wir dann
beispielsweise biografische übergang
nennen können beide typen gibt es
übrigens wirklich also beides sind
biografische auslöser für einen
pilgerschaft sowohl die lebenskrise als
auch der biografische übergang
das werden sie sehen wenn sie auch die
online vorlesung zur grounded theory
anschauen dann nämlich würde ihn gern
auch von der wirklichen
untersuchungsergebnissen unserer pilger
studien berichten
aber zunächst mal lassen sie uns noch
über den sechsten und letzten schritt in
der ration analyse sprechen nämlich die
entwicklung eines theoretischen modells
das ist ja unser ziel als forscher ja
wir wollen letztendlich unsere
forschungs frage beantworten und einen
theorie entwickeln und sehr häufig ist
dieses theoretische modell das wir
entwickeln in solchen biografischen
kontext tatsächlich eine typologie
es ist sehr schwer
ja also diese sechs schritte generation
analyse anhand eines beispiels durch zu
exerzieren also gerade die letzten
beiden schritte weil man dafür eine sehr
große menge von daten berücksichtigen
müsste ich möchte ihnen folgendes
vorschlagen wenn sie das modul m2 im
bachelorstudiengang politikwissenschaft
verwaltungswissenschaft soziologie
studieren dann werden sie gegen ende des
semesters im u
eine übungsaufgabe finden ja da stellen
wir ihnen das transkript eines negativen
interviews übrigens aus der pilger
studie zur verfügung und sie können
dieses transkript einmal mit einer
nation analyse analysieren sie werden
nicht ganz bis zu den letzten schritten
kommen weil es handelt sich nur um den
auszug eines transkript es sind
lediglich zwei seiten von insgesamt
vielleicht 50 seiten transkript und es
ist eben auch tatsächlich nur ein fall
was sie aber mal tun können und schon
das wird ihnen das prinzip generation
analyse deutlich und praktisch vor augen
führen ist sie können dieses transkript
in hude her nehmen und zunächst mal eine
formale textanalyse machen ja also
konkret machen sie die segmentierung des
interview transkripte sin erzähl
segmente in der praxis macht man das
häufig so dass man sich das transkript
ausdruckt und immer dann wenn von einem
ins nächste einzel segment gewechselt
wird dass man einfach einen senkrechten
strich macht hilfreich das möchte ich
noch einmal wiederholen bei der
abgrenzung von erzähl segmenten können
ihnen die rahmen schaltelemente sein
jahr also einleiten rahmen
schaltelemente und auch aus leitende
rahmen schaltelemente die markiert man
im regelfall indem man die rahmen
schaltelemente unterstreicht und dann
das war der dritte aspekt der formalen
textanalyse bestimmen sie für jedes der
von ihnen identifizierten segmente
handelt es sich um eine erzählung
handelt es sich um eine beschreibung
oder handelt es sich um eine
argumentation
das macht man in der forschungspraxis im
regelfall indem man bestimmte kürze
rechts an den rand neben das transkript
schreibt und da haben sich bestimmte
kürze eingebürgert für eine erzählung
schreibt man im allgemeinen set für eine
beschreibung in bevern argumentation n a
und wenn man dann innerhalb der
argumentation noch den spezialfall der
evaluation identifizieren möchte dann
verwendet man dafür dass kürze und sie
werden aber noch weiter kommen als bis
zu diesem rein formalen schritt sie
können auch anhand des transkripts in
mode
damit beginnen eine
strukturelle inhaltliche beschreibung
vor zunehmenden zweiten schritt
generation analyse und zwar eben indem
sie wie wir gesagt haben
die funktionalität eines geht es eher
segmentes bestimmen handelt es sich um
die haupt erzählung eine hintergrund
erzählung die belegung und ein schritt
können sie noch weiter gehen auf dem weg
zum strukturplan der biografie nämlich
sie können ganz simpel für jedes erzähl
segment eine überschrift bestimmen frei
formulieren und das ist in der
forschungspraxis sehr hilfreich ja also
sie müssen sich ja vorstellen in der
pilger studie hatten wir 2004 ein
transkript ja insgesamt 30 fälle und es
ist gar nicht so leicht über all diese
daten den überblick zu behalten
und da ist es sehr hilfreich wenn sie im
rahmen der narration analyse für jeden
einzelnen fall eine liste von
überschriften entwickelt haben worüber
spricht der erzähler ja eigentlich denn
das wird ihnen dabei helfen dann sehr
schnell mit einem kurzen blick auf
diesen überschriften liste sich nochmal
den biografischen verlauf dieses
einzelfalls in erinnerung zu rufen
lassen sie uns bevor sie mit dieser
aufgabe beginnen
ein kurzes beispiel anschauen
in diesem fall möchte ich ein sehr
stilisiertes beispiel ein künstliches
beispiel also diesmal handelt es sich
nicht um reale daten ist eine erzählung
die derart knapp ist dass sie
wahrscheinlich in der realität nicht so
vorkommt aber wir können uns dann ja
vielleicht trotzdem alle für uns
wichtigen elemente einer stegreif
erzählung noch mal vor augen führen
diese erzählung beinhaltet nämlich
tatsächlich nur die folgenden drei
zeilen also sie merken an meinem letzten
wochenende verhalten war viel los ich
war nämlich nicht nur bei stefan auf der
party sondern ich war am wochenende im
zoo das war mal wieder richtig schön
als die kinder noch klein waren war mit
der öfter und dann bin ich noch in die
eisdiele gegangen das war lecker deshalb
ist es da ja auch immer so voll
wenn wir jetzt mal versuchen ja diesen
diese kurze stilisierte erzählung im
erzähl segment
zu unterteilen dann wäre mein vorschlag
dass wir als erstes die ersten beiden
sätze als ein segment begreifen
ich war am wochenende im zoo das war mal
wieder richtig schön
meiner ansicht nach handelt es sich bei
diesem segment um die haupt erzählung ja
denn ich berichte ihnen davon was sich
am letzten wochenende getan habe genauer
gesagt tue ich das in diesem ersten satz
recht nah am wochenende im zog dabei
handelt es sich um eine erzählung
sie spielte in der vergangenheit und der
zweite satz das war mal wieder richtig
schön
den würde ich begreifen als einrahmen
schaltelemente es ist die abschließende
coda die dieses erzähl segment
abschließt sie kommt sehr schnell und
hat hohes gewicht in diesem stilisierten
beispiel im normalfall wäre meine
erzählung ja viel detaillierter ich war
am wochenende im zoo de hampel die
elefanten gesehen und waren dann noch im
neuen affenhaus und ich würde ihnen ja
viel detailreicher erzählen und dann
würde diese abschließende coda in der
relation geringeres gewicht haben hier
sticht sie jetzt sehr hervor aber es
handelt sich meiner ansicht nach um eine
abschließende oder deswegen
unterstreiche ich sie erst den rahmen
schaltelemente dann schreibe ich mir
rechts an den rand es handelt sich hier
um eine erzählung z
ja in die allerdings eine evaluation
eingebettet ist nämlich eben jene
abschließende oder und weil aber die
erzählung im vordergrund steht setze ich
das evaluation in klammern und
schließlich formuliere ich eine
überschrift und die könnte in unserem
fall jetzt zum beispiel lauten der
zoobesuch
das zweite ziel segment wäre der dritte
satz unserer kleinen erzählung als die
kinder noch klein waren war ich da ja
öfter in dem zoo ihren könnte es sich um
eine hintergrund erzählung dadurch dass
sich ein schiebe das ich früher öfter
ins oval bekommt nämlich mein aktueller
zu besuch am vergangenen wochenende eine
ganz andere bedeutung erscheint für mich
etwas besonderes etwas relevantes zu
sein und offenbar ist das etwas was ich
ihnen im rahmen einer stegreif erzählung
vermitteln möchte deswegen füge ich eine
hintergrund erzählung ein davon wie wir
früher mit den kindern öfter mal im zoo
waren handelt sich hier um eine
erzählung ich erkenne an diesen kurzen
stilisierten satz zunächst kein rahmen
schaltelemente und würde die überschrift
kleine kinder vergeben
das dritte segment wäre dann der besuch
in der eisdiele so lautet auch die
überschrift jetzt sind wir wieder in der
haupt erzählung denn am wochenende war
ich eben erst im 2 und dann in der
eisdiele
ich erzähle ihnen von dem prozess von
diesem tag am wochenende
es ist deutlich zu erkennen in diesem
fall dass ein neues segment folgt ja es
gibt nämlich dieses einleitende rahmen
scheidt element und dann wenn ich noch
in die spiele gegangen und auch diese
erzählung schließlich mit einer cola ab
mit einer bilanzierung es war lecker und
dann bleibt uns noch der letzte satz
unserer kurzen erzählung und hier
handelt es sich von der funktionalität
her meiner ansicht nach um eine pflege
erzählen ja diese evaluation das war
lecker am ende von erzähl segment 3
die belege ich jetzt mit einer
neuerlichen erzählung nämlich indem ich
sage deshalb ist es da ja auch immer so
voll vom text her handelt es sich hier
also um eine argumentation ganz klar zu
erkennen an diesem deshalb wenn ich
einen kausalen zusammenhang aufmache
dann handelt es sich dabei im regelfall
meine argumentation sie ist auch in der
gegenwart form formuliert und dient eben
dazu meine evaluation das war lecker zu
unterstreichen
ja so könnte es also ausschauen wenn sie
in mode das transkript herunterladen und
segmentieren rahmen scheidt elemente
unterstreichen die funktionalität des
segmentes bestimmen den text typ des
erzählt segmentes bestimmen das möchte
ich ihnen empfehlen zu tun gerne geben
würde ihnen dann am ende des semesters
in hude noch eine musterlösung wie wir
das transkript eine ration analytisch
aus werten würden
damit möchte ich für die narration
analyse schließen sie aber gerne auf die
dritte online vorlesungen zur
qualitativen sozialforschung verweisen
da werden wir uns mit dem mit der
grounded theory methodologie
beschäftigen und das passiert nicht rein
zufällig ja also auch fritz schütze
empfiehlt wenn ich mir den text die
stegreif erzählung mit einem aktions
analyse angeschaut habe um dann
letztendlich zu einem ergebnis im sinne
eines theoretischen modells oder einer
typologie zu gelangen eine grounded
theory methodologie vorzunehmen ja
insofern schließen beide
auswertungsmethoden wenn man so viel
aneinander an sehr spannend könnte es
übrigens auch sein wenn sie das in mode
zur verfügung gestellte transkript
einmal versuchen mit beiden
auswertungsmethoden zu analysieren
einerseits mit einer nation analyse
andererseits mit einer grauen bezieher
methodologie dann nämlich werden sie
sehen wie stark untersuchungsergebnisse
abhängig sind von der gewählten
auswertungsmethode sie werden ganz
andere dinge kennenlernen an diesem
transkript mit der narration analyse
werden sie auch diese formalen
strukturellen dinge eine erzählung
kennenlernen
wie wird das gerade gemacht haben mit
der grauen theorie werden sie dann einen
ganz deutlich größeren schritt der
analytischen abstraktion gehen können
und eben am ende vielleicht sogar typen
im sinne eines theoretischen modells
voneinander abgrenzen können insofern
macht es macht es viel sinn auch mal mit
beiden auswertungsmethoden auf ein und
dasselbe transkript zuschauen dazu
möchte ich sie einladen
für den moment soll es das gewesen sein
mit generation analyse und ich verbleibt
mit herzlichen grüßen erfragen